this script that you wrote while you
were still working on Wall Street where
did you start formulating the idea and
actually how did you start seeing like
the story structure and all of that I
mean you're so you're working what like
crazy hours on Wall Street but you still
had time to write this script or were
you fitting it in I just made time I
mean you can make time to do something
like particularly something like that
where it's you know it's not really
laborious it's not it's fun so you know
your impression of Wall Street maybe
it's not off base but there's time to do
it believe me those guys have plenty of
time to party and drive Ferraris and
so there's time to write a script
and I don't remember how long that
process took but we just sorta I don't
even remember I remember the script but
I don't remember how the idea came to be
it was it was just an idea and I was
like let me try to write it I think I
probably read some scripts and I knew it
wasn't I was gonna try to sell it or
anything or even make it it was just
sort of an exercise but with sex and
sushi I was clear that I'm gonna write
this thing that I'm going to make into a
movie myself and I was a quick process
to I I had an idea and I just sort of I
was listening to somebody talking about
their method recently and they say they
start with the story
and I don't I start with a character for
me sometimes it's a theme or some
something I want to explore but it's
certainly with a character it's not a
necessarily a story and I just sort of
get you know I sort of fill in that
character he's a sort of a skeleton and
once I'm really happy with that
character he or she in fact I'm writing
something now with a female lead but I
sort of point them in directions and
just see what happens and this story
comes from that that's not really
answering your question but yeah so the
theme of it was monogamy and you decided
to write it how long did it take you to
finish sex and sushi they actually write
yeah the writing portion maybe a six
weeks six weeks oh yeah month it was
quick okay it was all I did I mean it
was it was just like
and I knew I was probably gonna act in a
- and it was the film the finished film
is I'd say it's 30 percent improvised
that said there was a very deliberate
hard and fast script but we definitely
deviated from it but you know if I'm if
I'm engaged in a project if I'm writing
a script and I'm into it you know that's
all I'll - and it's quick I wrote a
script not long ago in two weeks and I
was really amped about it you know it's
all I thought about it's all I wanted to
do
you